that's what's so funny about these old
people saying that this generation is
soft it's like we've been at War their
entire lives and a lot of them served
you know it's up you can join the
military get a standing ovation at
halftime at a football game and then go
serve and 18 months later you're
homeless living under a bridge and the
same people that applauded you are now
screaming at you for to get a job I
don't think these kids are soft I think
what they're dealing with is they get I
mean we just used to have pain we didn't
have we didn't have to worry
about robots that were coming that you
know are going to roll their eyes around
thinking about you it's like 9 000
degrees in Des Moines Iowa right now
that's our food supply I just think
that's what old people do like if I see
one more stupid thing talking about how
uh people didn't complain in the 70s and
80s yeah they did there's just no video
of it